it's like i don't want to then think of
retiring and then suddenly being
you know poverty which is what it would
be if i had to retire now that's why
joanna owns a mortgage advice service
and hopes to retire in the next 15 years
despite spending her day-to-day helping
others understand the financial world
she fears a lack of pension advice when
she was younger will put her future in
jeopardy
i've got absolutely nothing it's crazy
really so
from starting out working all those
years ago
you know at 16 in those days there was
never any mention of pension so it was
never talked about in schools either
and then starting at 16 there was no
water enrollment workplace pension or
anything like that so i've literally in
my lifetime never had a conversation
with anyone
about pensions as such
she's one of many women at risk of
missing out on their retirement goals
according to a recent survey 45 percent
of women say a lack of funds puts them
off investing into their pension twenty
percent say they find it hard to
prioritize thinking towards retirement
while 15 say they don't have the
knowledge to save for their future it's
difficult to sort of prioritize i
suppose your future when you're trying
to pay for the here and now um another
issue women tend to face is they feel
like it's all too technical it's
something you know that they're not
familiar with they're not comfortable
with
that women don't particularly openly
discuss they think it's like a man's
world and the cost of living crisis has
only tightened retirement per strings
your pension is so far in the distance
even for us even though it isn't you
think i'll make it thinking i'll make up
for that you're living for today aren't
you
while there's still some time to go
before joanna and vicki hope to retire
the last thing they want is for that to
be delayed because of their pension pots
aisha zahid sky news